this week on quad riga syrian peace
poker Assad with best cards
the international community is talking
about a peace conference on Syria but it
seems just as likely the fighting will
continue the European Union has agreed
to lift its ban on providing arms to the
Syrian opposition France and Britain are
threatening to do so Russia condemns
that approach although Moscow continues
to provide military equipment to the
Assad government meanwhile the United
Nations says sending weapons is not
helpful and it's concentrating instead
on finding a political solution to the
divisions among international players
and within the Syrian opposition make it
easier for Assad to hold on to power and
when will the suffering of the civilian
population end your host this week
Melinda crane those are the questions we
want to address today on quad Riga hello
and welcome what's the likelihood that
the peace conference will take place and
will actually end the conflict we want
to talk about that today with three
experts who've been following the
situation in Syria closely and my guests
are Christina ACK she has reported from
Latin America as well as from several
countries in the Middle East for Morocco
to Iran since the 1960's writing for the
german magazine focus and the swiss
daily newspaper noisy shots I took and
she's been living and working in Tunisia
fawaz hello is part of serious secular
opposition movement he's been living in
exile here in germany since 2012 before
that he was a member of the Damascus
Spring movement and as a result of his
political activities he was imprisoned
by the Assad regime from 2001 to 2006
and finally I'm glad to welcome as
imelda Frau II he is senior fellow at
the berlin-based Institute for media and
communication policy a German Egyptian
he's a political scientist and
award-winning documentary filmmaker and
previously worked in the Middle East
Department of Germany's top think tank
and I'd like to stay with that poker
metaphor that we have in our title and
start out by asking all of you what odds
you give the peace conference i CLD
frawley what do you think will it go
ahead and does it have any chance of
success
I think in some ways the peace
conference will happen but currently I
believe likes this word peace or peace
process especially there's a lot of talk
about the peace process it's a very
premature kind of wording what I would
like to see now is stronger calls for a
general ceasefire as the United Nations
and the mediator latter Brahimi was
trying to do a year or two years ago I
think the first thing we need to do now
even before talking about delivering
arms and so on we should really bring
back the idea and really push for the
idea of a ceasefire in order that at
least the conference can happen in more
serene circumstances if anything it
looks like we're going rather in the
opposite direction at the moment yeah
fortunately but that's that's why it's
so crucially important really to bring
back the idea and very forcefully of a
ceasefire you know which worked out for
a very very short time after being a
beginning of the crisis or let's put it
frankly at the beginning of the Civil
War and we should work for that again
let's talk in just a moment about how
that might happen and how to do so fawaz
hello you used to be a part of the
Syrian National Council you resigned
complaining about it's very bitter
divisions the opposition remains
terribly divided uncertain at this point
if it will even attend the peace
conference what do you think I think
they will attempt the solution but but
yes they are there is a lot of cows
among the opposition and will stay like
that this is action for CH initely this
is part of the wrong approach which have
been taken from the first step there is
a real port inside Syria these real
pores have been just neglected by not
only for them by the International
International Committee but also by the
Syrian opposition and because of that
also we have curves inside Syria cuz
with all levels political levels
military levels this is part of our
problem in Syria I think the
in any other point of view the senior
position has been under pressure all the
time till this moment while we don't
have we don't see any kind of pressure
among the regime itself you mentioned
for the ceasefire for example I think
this is part of an Annie it's not
conditioned just preventing the the
situation to start a real negotiation
which can leave you for a certain point
when you have an agreement while what's
happening like you said is it's it's a
poker game actually it's a gambling and
gambling everybody lose this is
situation only the chasm is winning at
last because it's a casino yeah actually
the casino is the international
community international community
emselves by running yet look you have a
major thing a major point and I keep
asking all the politicians in the other
diplomatic approach in the West American
Deutsch etc are you really supporting
get rid of this regime and building a
real democracy in Syria the answer will
be yes but actually what they have been
done is no because what they are trying
to do since the beginning of this of
this revolution just trying to keep the
core of the regime they want something
like Yemenis for example a scenario
which keep the core of the regime to
have maybe a graduate reform to takes
10-20 years that don't matter about that
and don't look for the fort for what's
really happening on the ground it's not
like seven sure I just want to stay with
the casino a moment and talk about the
role of the international community
Christina they did decide now in the EU
this week to lift the weapons embargo
allowing some European countries
potentially to go ahead with weapons
deliveries as female differ
mentioned a moment ago anything but a
ceasefire in that case if that does go
forward how helpful do you think that
step was in terms of facilitating peace
talks well not at all because it shows
clearly how divided even the West is and
even Europe is they don't have a common
foreign policy and that's very negative
how can they have a voice if the
conference will go ahead next month if
they are so divided and delivering
weapons now and they said only after the
conference they will start delivering
weapons they missed the time where it
was useful and and now it's much too
late to deliver weapons it only will
continue the Civil War the argument the
argument of those countries that wanted
the embargo lifted is that this is a way
to put pressure on Assad Assad but it
will be the contrary because now he has
a pretext not to attend the conference
and so it's it's it's a gambling like
you said with this decision and and the
worse is that it made quite clear how
divided even Europe is how will they
speak with one voice if they can't agree
on this is very important point let's
take a brief look at just how sorry but
we have some voices that show us just
how divided Europe truly is in this case
let's take a brief look at that report
we would only take the step of sending
arms in company with other nations in
carefully controlled circumstances and
in compliance with international law but
this decision today gives us the
flexibility in the future to respond to
a worsening situation or to a refusal of
the Assad regime to negotiate I'm
personal not in favor of there
cuz I think European Union should hold
the line and we are peace movement and
not war movement get an event with the
lifting of the embargo makes the
situation even more complicated at the
very least creating a serious obstacle
along the path towards the international
conference on Syria the social room is
not on the confidence to pursue his own
yet sadhus nonsense we should
concentrate on enabling a political
solution the real answer to serious
problem will be a political one that's
why I want to see this conference
actually take place that's it yes I must
so mr. al-jaafari your view getting some
support there from the German Chancellor
but indeed a cacophony of voices coming
out of Europe yeah and I would like to
come back to the image of the poker game
I think there is no poker game at all
it's not a game where the winner takes
it all I think we're in a game where
there will be only losers we are in a
lose-lose situation nobody will get out
of it if there is not very soon at least
as I mentioned a ceasefire we are
already very close to worst-case
scenario which means the total
fragmentation of Syria x equals last
scenario and much worse which will
affect the neighboring country countries
will go back to the balkanization of
Iraq which was already in some ways
vulcanized for the fragmentation of
Lebanon and fragmentation of Syria which
will have long-term aplia implications
which will be disastrous for the region
for regional stability for economic
development so again I'm we are not we
are not in a game anyway but we're in a
total lose-lose situation at this stage
so really appeal to everybody to to
attend such conferences and to implement
as quickly as possible ceasefire and not
to deliver very quickly weapons to
aggravate the situation at the State
Forest ello what's your assessment on
the subject of weapons deliveries do the
Syrian rebels
truly need weapons now in order to hold
their own in order to give them the
strength to be a counterweight to the
regime actually let me tell you that the
scenarios have been fighting since about
18 months without a real support from
the international community without them
in spite of this Peugeot which has been
put upon the weapons so I want to try to
explain what's happening as I'm
analyzing here and not giving a
propaganda well in this program and I
what's happening that the Russian and
the European is trying to to to put
pressure upon each other's direction
said okay we are going to deliver a
s-300 missiles to that to the anti-graft
massage to the regime and they will not
to do that I'm sure about that okay well
not to know of course they're holding
back on it right now Israel this is
simply because this is a main point they
don't care who is Assad or anybody is
rolling Syria but this kind of massage
shouldn't be in the hand of whatever
will be in Syria and in the other hand
we have the rypien which it's like we
say one stage 11 play but everybody got
his rule said we are going to arm the
Syrian opposition by the way we start to
hear that about one year ago nine months
ago is like a pit have been throwing to
to that to the to the opposition to to
draw them to the negotiations and now
they said this if will happen it will be
starting from August after Jenny the
Geneva is going to start so they are
connecting everything we should and also
I think they were not arming the are not
going to arm the Syrian opposition this
is not part of their strategy is just a
pressure before any Geneva negotiation
is the pressure effective or are we in a
lose-lose situation as we just heard
from us
LT fry we I agree with mr. deflower that
it's a lose-lose totally the situation
now but the question is how we are going
to stop that we already have very bad
consequences is waiting for us we
already have we have to do that because
actually the move and the act is too
late this kind of confidence will be
very successful before one year maybe
well Javier but now it's it became out
of date I think there is a main
obstacles here look everybody go to
Geneva especially the regime and his
Allah look for Geneva not a strategical
way to against our supposed to be held
in Geneva just a reminder yeah it is
maneuver its maneuver technical
political maneuver to gain more time and
to gain more land this is what they are
doing look on the ground we have tens of
thousands now of foreigner fighters from
Hezbollah and Iranian and Shia fighters
attention but the best people simply
holding the flags of sectarian war it
was very very hard yeah in time yeah
absolutely so Christina hack how do we
stabilize the situation enough to get
people talking to each other in a
constructive way what is the path
forward the idea of course behind
lifting that Wafaa of that weapons
embargo to put pressure both on Assad
but naturally also on Russia is it
working I don't see it I don't see it's
working and as most of you said it's a
lose-lose situation and the big loser is
leather for Syrian people of course
because the suffering is beyond
imagination and of course as long as it
drags on the more the conflict will
spread to the neighboring countries
especially I mean Hizballah is involved
since a long time but Hassan Nasrallah
de is that getting that support from
neighboring countries and from Russia
what do you do yes supporting any more
on both sides ok so you
do I knew equal equalize the odds well
you can have a conference but it's just
winning time nothing else I don't see
that there can be a positive result only
as long as the pressure from other
countries be it Israel be it the United
States are very important Russia then
they have to sit together in earnest and
discuss a ceasefire at least but at the
moment when the Secretary General of the
Hezbollah who is very strong and very
military disciplined fighters when he
openly says we have to back the Assad
regime because if not we are losses we
are the big defenders against Israel so
that brings Israel on on the plane and
who attacked twice some convoys of arms
supposed to be in San total Hezbollah so
it's becoming it's winding and Lebanon
is already dragged in since months not
only since two weeks or so you have
Fighting's in the northern city of
Tripoli since more than a year and the
rocket attacks in the southern suburbs
of Beirut where Hezbollah has the
headquarters that shows that it's it's a
globalization of the war because you
have these jihadists from other Arab
countries who are fighting on the rebel
side and you have of course Iran and
Hezbollah now supporting the regime it's
how do you cope these groups and the
danger is welded Jordan is a poor
country it's overwhelmed with Syrian
refugees the same with Lebanon there are
almost as many Syrians now living in or
seeking shelter in Lebanon then they
have in abidjan so it's the official
numbers are not the exact ones because
the Syrians are Fred to register and
Lebanon because the Syrian Mahabharata
the Secret Service is still working in
Lebanon so it's a very fragile situation
and there is of course hope for
this conference in Geneva that they can
put a lid on this fire a little bit at
least that a few different strands there
that I would like to pick up but let's
start with something we haven't talked
about a lot namely the role of the
jihadis mr. LD Fraleigh has written a
book about the mystique the myths of
jihad and the way that it does attract
young Islamic warriors to the cause what
is your assessment of the role of such
groups in the Syrian opposition at the
moment so the jihadist fighters in Syria
still a minority but they're a very very
influential minority and as jihad is
belief in some kind of salvation as some
sectarian Salvationists they're highly
modified a motive motivated firefighters
who don't mind dying in a sense that
they believe once it does ill enter
paradise as martyrs straight away so
they're very dangerous and efficient
fighters and so they have some kind of
influence far beyond far beyond their
strengths in terms of numbers I was
reading reports from people who have
been in Syria but recently in spending a
lot of time with Syrian opposition
fighters and they're saying the jihadi
serve as examples for other Syrian
opposition fighters the risk of the
jihadi movement being very present in
Syria is obviously that we might see the
same thing as we have seen in Iraq huge
influx of foreign fighters who don't
really care about Syria but care about
global jihad and mighty eventually
returned to to after having created
havoc in Syria itself might create havoc
somewhere else this brings me to three
other very important points I would like
to make we were talking with a talking
but sorry about my stay with the jihadis
briefly and just asked if i was telling
say was a jolly good I'll stay with the
jihadist you didn't mention two other
very important regional players saudi
arabia and qatar
far corrected was the jihad it's very
connected with GG Allin especially Saudi
Arabia Wes promoted jihad outside its
own country for a long time since
decades will might itself find itself
not a very very delicate situation
because those Saudi gre's who have been
there and those movement Niger Saudis
created I wouldn't go so far into the
911 comparison here might return to
Saudi Arabia and create start a new
jihadi campaign against the Saudi state
for example but I think we should really
talk about qatar and saudi arabia some
stages yes indeed I'd like to come back
to that into the idea of a sectarian
conflict across the whole region but
let's let's stay on that jihadi question
as far west ello what's your assessment
knowing the opposition from the inside
how strong is the influence of extremist
groups and is it growing actually like
masala you say they are still a
materially affected multi this is a
reality minority is sorry is this is a
real fact on the on the ground and
unfortunately before running we don't
have that those people in Syria for one
half year that the revolution was going
on without those people but the neglect
of the international community don't
care about what you hear about the
politicians like the American and how
missed how they are conscious about
there's a joke by the way in Syria said
Oh mr. ban ki-moon and mrs. Clinton is
not expressing their there they are they
are worried since one week was the
problem they have something so just we
don't have a real support for the people
who is fighting with the ground yes
since one year we start to have a small
amount of weapons light weapons and
ammunition from Qatar and Saudi Arabia
through Turkey this is effect but it's
still a very small amount we don't have
any anti crafts for a massage etcetera
etcetera because there's a lot of
pressure by the international community
especially by the united state and they
repent for not delivering that what in
the other side you have you have for
example 1400
a ton of weapons and machine every week
Richard the Syrian regime so all the
whole support for the other side without
any support for the Syrian sighs that's
why I asked you a moment ago do the
rebels need more weapons to equalize the
situation you did not directly answer my
question before actually disables sills
two years they are trying to balance
their situation and they are succeeding
with that with the small amount of a
phone which they they have the main
question that yes there is problem of
jihadis is going to be created in Syria
how we can't deal with it its equity I
think I think and this is what my mum
and my approach for that we should have
a real partnership from the beginning
and still now we should have this real
partnership with those people who is
fighting is not to having putting more
pressure for not supplying the arms to
push the opposition and to be weak and
to go to the attitude to this conflict
because we are in this way telling the
hopeless people inside it look yeah and
as for the help from the devil doesn't
doesn't matter what this devil jihad is
not jihad is well elect and this is a
situation look I want to go back for one
minute please lay the main obstacles we
have in this negotiation in all the
crisis is the shot I said his family
some people around him this is the real
pressure should be implemented by the
international community to get rid of
this if this one like what's happening
how they would say they've been trying
to do that without success they would
say it it is all in the hands of Russia
look how yes Syndic 10 threaten Hank
that we are going to send 10 missile
cross massage to get rid of you I didn't
leave Sita without one or two or three
weeks to simply or we go to the Russian
and and and said the American not me
look we are going to be enforced
directly we will really support the
opposition with with with weapons and
they know that if we have real weapons
and real support for the weapons within
few months ago get rid of
the regime or you have to pick a real
pressure to get it over shall I said
they will response for that because we
don't have a serious pressure a serious
special look the American is just
putting the Russian as a as a proxy for
440 for the policy actually they are
very close with direction with their
policy Americans are very weary of war
and Barack Obama has been very reluctant
to us to make any kind of commitment
Christina Eric do you see the u.s.
moving toward playing a stronger and
more direct role and would it really be
helpful twice no I would say because
it's the experience with Iraq and
Afghanistan where they left just a mess
much worse than before and even if
Senator McCain now slipped in for a
couple of hours to northern Syria
because he is the vice pro sending
weapons and but I think one has to go
back a little bit to alter Georgia Libya
and that's why they are so divided the
United States and Russia because Russia
agreed to help Syria and have a no-fly
zone and then it was much more it was
much more than just a no-fly zone and
that's what Russia never will forget and
they will forgive and that's why they
are backing awesome but it's not only
Russia backing them it's also Iran and I
think that is a very important point to
because Saudi Arabia and Qatar they are
very much afraid about Iran and they
want to curb Iran briefly leaving that
aside one more question on the US Obama
of course had declared a red line in
regard to the use of chemical weapons
there is where our red line there are
chemical weapons where you so the past
cases where has it been a problem that
he declared the red line and didn't act
on it well of course in a certain sense
it's it's it's a problem because where
is the red line now they said that they
were using chemical weapons were used in
a small scale but nevertheless but then
they say
while it's not clear if the regime use
it or maybe some rebels uses so
indecisive um Susan oh I ok Anika good
one to the light two killed a few
hundred or two thousand people chemical
weapons or to kill 100,000 people
shooting them is there is no big
difference regarding the this red line
from look there is a lot of pressure
inside the American administration
against mr. Obama because actually he is
not taking any serious acts it's not to
send the military group to Syria or even
the the no-fly zone we are talking for
example about arming the opposition I'm
the opposite this is not a direct
involved by by the Thetas allowing for
the European or for the Qatar and Saudi
to give a real support of arming the
opposition there is any air pressure
inside the American administration and
mr. Obama just trying to response to
this pressure but actually he is not
serious to do anything look when they
when you look at what's happening in
Iraq today are you convinced that US
intervention would really be a
constructive contribution you can't
compare with two situations it's totally
different situation nobody asked the
American to come to Syria and by the way
the Syrian people will fight the
American they just come to see their
nobody else ask them to come to city we
are talking about totally different
situation can we really be so sure the
American writer Tom Friedman who knows
the Middle East very very well said
recently he thinks we're no longer
talking about an Arab Spring we're
talking about an Arab thirty years war
of religion a sectarian conflict across
the entire Middle East this comes back
of course to the idea of Saudi Arabia
Qatar lined up against Shiite countries
like Iran do you think that is what's in
store we're talking about two things at
the same time we're talking about an
Arab Awakening we're talking about an
hour
spring tremendous things have have
happened and we always knew that this
would be very very difficult transitions
and we always knew that there is a
stronger Shiite Sunni divide in the Arab
world which bears risks but it doesn't
need to stay that way it doesn't really
need to stay that way that's why it's so
crucial to stabilize places like like
Syria Iraq and Lebanon which has a
playing grounds in in terms of the sea
air she is only divided and I would like
to make very brief three points again
Saudi Arabia and Qatar we also need to
apply a tremendous amount of pressure on
those countries not to use Syria for
their proxy war against the Shiites and
if we don't do that we won't have any
chance to pacify Syria second point
talking about a ceasefire again the
initial lucky Brahimi plan to miss him
seems to be still quite valid the Arabs
Sierra Sierra leagues the Arab League
takes for once again a very active
stance everybody agrees on a ceasefire
controlled by the Arab League eventually
by the United Nations at least for some
time to stabilize the situation and this
brings me to my third point is a
military option let's look again at
Libya for example everybody in the West
is claiming this was an easy
intervention terms have lasted a couple
of weeks to overthrow Gaddafi Syria is
not Libya in terms of geography it's
very difficult in terms of support for
the different fraction I believe Bashar
through the other ways and the
Christians and other groups has still
much more support then had a fee ever
had but you know what the death toll of
the Syrian intervention was 50 or 60,000
Libyan debt this art offer people of six
million people so the coast of this
interventions are tremendous if you
apply this to 30 million Syrians will go
get to a desktop of 250
or 300,000 just for a couple of weeks
and intervention we already have between
18 and a 100,000 Syrians that so um I
believe arming is no solution and the
military intervention is no solution at
all again just purely technically
military if Great Britain and France
push for the armament of this year no
position which kind of arms up as I
going to provide what is it going no no
but once your see what I ain't going to
which kind of arms would be efficient to
bring down the Assad regime I think it's
a full-scale military intervention if
you give a couple of anti-aircraft
missiles or a couple of Tanks this will
just prolonged and aggravate horrible
civil war so mr. Taylor two points their
military intervention basically
completely counterproductive and why not
try the Brahimi peace plan what's your
response actually I want to remind you
that mr. kofi annan and before that we
have the Arab League have been sent
their observer to Syria and the regime
has destroyed that that opportunity
since one year ago it's all they have
been you jaani used this way we are not
talking about military intervention
military military ends or solution for
this crisis if we have to go for a
political end for this way I told you
there's a main obstacles Bashar Assad
and his family and some people around
him the main pressure should be how to
get rid of those people with any mean in
this way we can open the gate for some
people inside the regime to start this
negotiation so to explain to me
concretely how to get rid of the other
clan giving the right message for the
Assad regime and for the Russian by the
international community that we are
going to supply really arming the Syrian
opposition and we are going to help them
even with get rid of him visit
physically it's part of the of the of
the options we have this is the way how
you can obtain the negotiation with
this one of the international community
would you realistically expect to be
willing to do that realistically to whom
would you address that message to the
American do you really think you're
gonna persuade them no no no tell know
that we couldn't persuade them because I
told from the beginning they have them
in their mind Yemen is seen as you which
push them to believe that this regime
look we are talking about alois minority
who's controlling the whole country
since 50 years they are ten percent
minority their control everything the
security the army etc etc etc and the
international community like to keep the
structure of the state while this is
impossible it's it's to understand we
can't wait and said you have to do that
you have to get rid of jihadist you have
to go to the political solution we have
to prepare the situation for the
political solution otherwise otherwise
it's just a wishful thinking since like
we have hearings since two years and we
will push for more fragmentation for for
the area and let me communicate about
the sectarian war in the area before
five years in 2006 when the Israeli
attack has below in Lebanon half a
million of sheer has been crossed the
border to Syria have the Shia of Lebanon
they have been welcomed warmly in Syria
including al Kosair which have been
under the sea's right now they are
really worried they don't have a tent
they have been in houses inside the
house inside home they have been very
good life during this few months then
they go back so it was not a sectarian
feeling what's going on now look there's
an Iranian plan for all the area this
plan has been started 1979 after how
many take over near on and it's using a
lot of tools and a loaf of instrument
part of it is talking that we are there
for
think Israel one of this instrument to
support Hezbollah and now Bashar Assad
is main player in this big plan for for
the Aryan so they are fighting for their
interest it's not a sunni-shia at least
from from the suicidal race very
important point the very important point
they're just power struggle between Iran
and Saudi Arabia for which the region
plays a tremendous coast so those huge
players creates or exacerbate
antagonisms to a degree which present a
high-risk high-risk them to the
elevations of the background because the
United States officially steps back but
they are training since long time either
under on the Turkish side on the board
of a service Syrian under Jordanian side
they are training rebels they are
providing also some kind of weaponry so
the CIA is present as it's a long time
so it's it's not the official line and
well I and and one has to look also at
Israel because in the last days there's
a lot of talking about going to war I
mean they tell us a little bit more
about the role of Israel and the role of
Hezbollah Hezbollah of cut of course
their recent announcements very much
raising concerned that it's also
changing the odds in the others what
kind of pressure what kind of pressure
can we bring on Hezbollah by what means
and what do you expect the role of
Israel to be as we move forward while
Israel is very orator of course and
that's why they attack twice weapons
convoy is from Syria to Lebanon if they
can really stop it is another question
that quite interesting is that in the
end of the 90s the Lebanese airline
opened the direct flights Beirut Tehran
and about two years later they're well
no more flights that I asked the manager
what happened and he said too much
smuggling and so I said aha Hezbollah
weapons he said hmm
so there was a direct link always and it
still exists in some way now it's flying
to Damascus and comes on and you can't
control the the border if you know the
mountain area and it's not controlled
and you have you were mentioning Kaseya
what's now in the end the real and the
point of interest the city it's very
important for the Assad regime because
it's the link between Damascus and the
coastline where the Alouettes come from
and it's very important also for the
rebels because it's close to the
Lebanese border in the north where all
the weapons from Lebanon come to the
rebels so there is when you look at the
prices of a machine gun you could get it
in the beginning for fifty dollar in in
Beirut and the the prices are rocketing
so it's a lot of smuggling going on and
Israel of course must be worried because
they knew in 2006 well they attack
Lebanon every half year they bombed the
infrastructure that the power stations
bridges main roads so every half a year
because they didn't want to Lebanon to
come up as a maybe becoming dangerous as
regional partners in economic partners
and the other one who you can't forget
but then in 2006 they invaded Lebanon
more or less and then they had to
realize that Hezbollah is really a power
they can't fight and and everyone one in
Lebanon said okay they were withdrawing
the Israelis it's an unfinished business
they will come back and so maybe they
are just waiting for the pretext now
that Hezbollah is involved in Syria and
with Assad regime father and son the
Israelis were happy in some way because
they were never ever any attacks
crossing the border so it was a stable
situation as energy far we are we likely
to see a hot conflict start up again in
Lebanon it's already I had pronounced my
cell phones likelihoods bad terms there
is a risk obviously is a risk but let me
put this question into a bigger regional
original picture what's happening in the
in Lebanon Syria and Iraq is really the
product of a horrible badly done
decolonization of the whole area we are
still we're talking we're still thinking
and talking in terms of nation-states
but what we're really talking about our
X ultimum countries which have been
managed totally different was huge
minority problems with overlapping the
minorities sometimes it's born and draw
a border straw drawn by see me drunk
French or English officers and now we
are coming and now now becoming coming
back to all this and if he really opens
the lid if Syria explodes we'll go to
this pre-colonial situation but we'll
find totally new regional alliances
Sonia Sonia Sonia and now is Sunni Sunni
alliance between Iraqi Sunnis who feel
they're in a minority and Syrian Sun is
so it's a potential risk of this breakup
of the state to Kurdish the certain
cards who look very much as a rocky
brothers who have already achieved a
degree of autonomy Zia Tripoli Sony's
out of Lebanon who feel they're a
minority in their own country and which
would like to come closer to draw to
close it is a Syrian Sony's so I'm sorry
much like the Balkans which is in the
beginning that's is that's a bet
decolonization of the Ottoman Empire
let's really go back in history so we
have exact him on the sense that and
we'll really have to really have this
kind of situation which might be in some
way at each other people can have
tremendous risks yea foas seller last
word for you the peace conference is
supposed to be held in June possibly
early July what do you think will it
bring any results if you don't put the
military option on the table really you
can't win with the political track
okay thank you very much to all of you
for being with us today and thanks to
all of you out there for tuning in see
you soon
you
you